let's work through this tricky question
we want the integral from negative pi to
Pi of the absolute value of pi minus the
absolute value of x DX
now when you have an absolute value it's
best to work through cases so suppose
that X is between 0 and Pi in that case
the absolute value of x will be equal to
X then Pi minus the absolute value of x
will be equal to Pi minus X and that
will be greater than zero If instead X
is between negative pi and 0 the
absolute value of x will be equal to the
opposite of X so Pi minus the absolute
value of x will be equal to pi plus X
and that will also be greater than zero
so we can graph this out in the positive
domain it Slants down in the negative
domain it Slants up
so we want the integral which will be
the area of this triangle which has a
base of 2 pi and a height of Pi so this
will be 2 pi times pi all over 2 and
that gives us the answer of pi squared